The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last time we
talked about processing
of cues that are used for
binaural localization of sound.
Those being the interaural
time and interaural level
differences.
And we have those cues because
the ears are physically
separated on the
sides of our head.
And because of the physical
characteristics of sound,
for example, the
velocity of sound in air.
And we talked toward the
end of last time's lecture
about the neural processing
of interaural time differences
in the Medial Superior
Olive, or MSO.
And we talked about
the Jeffress model
and how it can help recreate
a neural mapping that
has ITD sensitivity.
And that's the subject of
the assignment for this year.
So I just put the text
for the assignment
up here, just to
mention that there
was something added
on at the end.
But the first paragraph
of the assignment
is basically the lecture and the
sketch of the Jeffress model.
Except that these
days, people are
thinking that the axonal
delay lines are not
how the delay is created in
the medial superior olive.
And so I ask you for two other
possible neural mechanisms
that weren't originally
postulated by Jeffress
that could create delays.
So that's sort of the
heart of the assignment.
The second paragraph talks
about some further updates
to the Jeffress model.
And there is a paper
that is attached
to last time's lecture.
The paper by [? Brandt ?] et al
where they discuss extensively
some challenges, they call
them, to the Jeffress model.
And I might call them amendments
to the Jeffress model,
but things that
weren't originally
postulated by Jeffress that
have come to light because
of more recent experimental
studies that don't fit
with the original version
and their updates.
And finally, we've been
talking quite a lot
about cochlear implants.
And there's a very nice
passage on cochlear implants
in the textbook that I
encourage you to read.
And the final paragraph
of the assignment
is, what problems would
cochlear implant users, even
those with a left and a
right cochlear implant, have
if they use the Jeffress
model to localize sounds?
So that's a little
bit of thinking
to solve that last problem, too.
But based on what
we have talked about
and what the textbook talks
about for cochlear implants,
you should be able to come
up with an answer for that.
So any questions
on the assignment?
It relates very heavily
to last time's lecture
on the Jeffress
model and the MSO.
And I guess-- it
doesn't say here,
but three to five pages would
be appropriate, I think.
And it's due on
December 4, which
is the day of the lab tour.
So on that class day, which
is a week from Wednesday,
we'll meet at the
Massachusetts Eye and Ear
Infirmary instead
of meeting here.
So we'll send you a reminder.
And I think now on
the website there
are directions to get to
Mass Eye and Ear Infirmary.
It's just a simple one-stop
on the Red Line subway
to get there.
So the assignment
will be due then.
And then I'll be
able to grade it
before we have a review session.
And we'll talk about the correct
answers for this assignment
at the time of the
review session, which
is the next class
after December 4.
So today, I want to
march into new things.
Now, we're going to talk
about neural processing
of interaural level differences.
Remember if a sound is off
to one side of my head,
it's going to appear at a higher
sound level in the ear facing
that sound source than
it will appear in the ear
away from the sound source.
So we talked about how big
these cues were last time.
And they can, for high
frequencies, be maximally 20 dB
in Interaural Level
Difference, or ILD.
So those are processed,
at least starting
in the lateral
superior olive, which
is another nucleus in the
superior olivary complex, which
is close to the medial superior
olive we've been talking about.
So we'll talk about
the process in the LSO.
Then, we'll talk
about projections
of that nucleus and the MSO.
And other parts of
the superior olive
to the next higher
center in the brainstem,
which in the auditory pathway is
the Inferior Colliculus, or IC.
So we'll be talking extensively
about the inferior colliculus,
which is a large
nucleus in the brainstem
just caudal to the
superior colliculus
that you folks talked
about extensively
in the visual part
of the course.
In the IC, you have some
interesting neural responses
that relate to something
called time/intensity trading.
I misspelled it.
Not a very good speller, sorry.
Which we'll talk
about and define.
We'll talk about some
interesting characteristics
of room acoustics, like
reflections off the wall,
and how those don't completely
upset the apple cart of knowing
where a sound is coming
from because of things
like the precedence effect.
And finally, we'll end up with
auditory pathways in the barn
owl.
So this species of birds
has very well-developed
auditory systems.
And some work at
Caltech has shown
that these animals
have so-called "space"
maps in a certain
part of their brain.
That is, there's
a mapping of where
the sound is in external
space into space
in part of their brain
called the optic tectum.
And we'll go over that.
And the reading for today is on
how that space map is plastic
and can be changed
by experience.
So we'll talk about neuronal
plasticity of the space map.
OK, so let's get started.
So the neural processing of the
interaural level differences
in the lateral superior olive.
By contrast to what Jeffress
cooked up for the MSO,
this neural circuit
is very simple.
And here's how it runs.
The Lateral Superior Olive on
the left side is here, the LSO.
There's an LSO on the
right side as well,
but the circuit is shown for
the one on the left side.
This LSO on the
left side gets input
from the cochlear
nucleus on the left side.
That's excitatory input.
And it gets input from the
right side that's inhibitory.
And the way the
inhibitory input works
is the cochlear nucleus
neurons on the right side
project across the midline
and into another sub-nucleus
of the superior olivary
complex designated here
as the MNTB, which I think
is spelled out here--
the Medial Nucleus of
the Trapezoid Body.
So if you look at these
sections under the microscope,
there's a lot of
crossing fibers here.
And they sort of look, if you
have a lot of imagination,
like a trapezoid.
And this nucleus is within
those crossing fibers.
So it's within the
trapezoid body.
That's how it gets its name.
And the MNTB neurons have
inhibitory neurotransmitter.
So the cochlear nucleus
excites these MNTB neurons,
but then they're inhibitory
and they send their axons
to the LSO.
And they spill out or
release their inhibitory
neurotransmitter on
to the LSO neurons.
So how does this
circuit work then
if the sound is off to
this side of the slide,
off to the left side?
The sound will be of higher
level in the left ear
and it will exert a
high excitatory effect
on the cochlear nucleus here.
And the LSO will be
excited in a big way.
Of course, a little
bit of that sound
is going to come over
here to the right side,
but it won't excite the right
auditory nerve quite as much.
And this pathway that
eventually becomes inhibitory
won't be as strongly activated.
And so the inhibition
will be less.
So there's an interplay between
excitation here and inhibition.
And in this case with the
sound off to the left side,
the excitation will rule.
And so here's a plot of the
firing of an individual LSO
neuron that gets
all these inputs.
And if the sound is off
to the left side, which
is supposed to be this axis--
this is an axis of Interaural
Level Difference,
or ILD, where here
on the left side of the
graph the ipsilateral level
is greater than the
contralateral level.
That case, the LSO
neuron will be excited
and it'll have a
lot of response,
a high amount of firing.
On the other hand, if the sound
is over here on the right side,
it will activate in a big
way the right pathway,
which will result in a big
inhibitory input to the LSO
neuron on that left
side of the brain.
Sure, some of the sound
is going to come over here
and activate the left pathway.
But that excitation
won't be as strong.
So in that case, the
inhibition will rule.
The LSO neuron gets a
large amount of inhibition
and its firing rate will be low.
Its response will be low
because it's inhibited.
Now, what happens if the sound
is right in the middle, 0 ILD?
Sound is coming straight ahead.
The sound is the
same at the two ears.
And thus, the ILD is 0.
Well, it sort of depends
on how you wire this up.
Whether the balance
is perfectly balanced.
Then, maybe it would
be a 50% response.
In the case of this graph,
it looks like the inhibition
is a little bit stronger for
equal sound on the two sides.
And so the inhibition
dominates at 0 ILD.
But in actuality, if you
record from the LSO neurons,
you find all sorts
of combinations.
Those that have 50%
response rate at 0,
those that have 90% response,
and those that have 10%
like this guy.
So this is a very
simple circuit.
No coincidence detection.
No delay lines.
Well, you should
kind of do a heads
up here when I talk
about delay and timing
because this pathway coming
from this contralateral side
is a lot longer.
The axons have to
cross the midline.
And then there's a
delay here because
at the synapse between
one axon's terminal
and the cell bodies
of the MNTB neurons,
there's a little bit of delay.
This neurotransmitter
has to be released.
The MNTB neurons have to get
excited and, finally, fire.
So all that can take a
half a millisecond or so.
It turns out this axon
is a very thick one.
This cochlear
nucleus neuron here
that provides this crossing axon
is called the globular bushy
cell.
And we talked about
that a little bit
when we talked about
the cochlear nucleus.
It's not important
exactly what type it is,
but this has the
thickest axon, really,
of all the axons in
the auditory pathway.
So it gets across the
midline very quickly.
And there is a
synaptic delay here.
So the contralateral input is
going to come in a little bit
later.
So sometimes in recording
some LSO neurons,
you find a little bit of
excitation from this side.
And then right after,
an instant later,
a half a millisecond
or a millisecond later,
you find a big inhibition.
And so that can happen.
The sum total though,
in the case where
the sound is off to
the contralateral side,
is a dominant inhibition.
Now, we haven't talked
about neural inhibition
much in our class, so maybe
we should just mention it.
And I should definitely
mention the type
of inhibitory transmitter
that's used here.
So we have the MNTB neurons
are coming like this
and sending their axons
to the LSO neurons.
And they're inhibiting them.
That's what I mean by
this minus sign here.
And so this is an
inhibitory synapse
which inhibits the LSO neurons.
One can ask the
question is, what
is the inhibitory
neurotransmitter?
And in this case,
it's called glycine.
So glycine is released from
the MNTB neuron terminals
onto the LSO neurons.
And so how is that known?
Well, it's sort of a lot of
little pieces in a puzzle here.
The MNTB neurons themselves have
the metabolic machinery that
can make the glycine.
They transport it down
their nerve axons.
Glycine is actually a
fairly common chemical
in all cells of the body,
but these MNTB neurons
are packed with it.
If you use antibodies
to glycine,
they stain these
neurons much darker
than most neurons in the brain.
There are other glycinergic
neurons, of course.
Their axons and their
terminals are darkly stained.
The lateral superior
olive neurons
have glycine receptors on them.
When you put little
puffs of glycine,
which you can from a pipette.
You can release
glycine from a pipette
in an artificial
recording situation.
When you puff glycine
on to LSO neurons,
they are inhibited greatly.
So they certainly have
the receptors for glycine.
There are uptake systems to
take up the glycine after it's
been released so that the
inhibition doesn't stay on
forever.
When you stimulate, if you go
in and stimulate electrically
these MNTB neurons, you find
the LSO neurons are inhibited.
So a lot of little pieces of
the puzzle go into the idea
that these are
glycinergic neurons.
And this glycinergic
input is very
important in ILD sensitivity.
Now, a lot of textbooks will say
the ITD sensitivity is created
in the MSO and the ILD
sensitivity is created here
in the LSO.
And we're done with it.
But that's probably not true.
This is such a simple
circuit, you probably
have other places in the
auditory pathway where
ILD sensitivity is also created.
For example, you have nuclei
in the lateral lemniscus--
the pathway going up to
the inferior colliculus.
You have such circuits
probably right
in the inferior
colliculus and maybe
at other levels of the pathway.
So this is not the
only place where
we find circuits
for ILD sensitivity.
Now, we talked about last
time how these ILD cues
were prominent at
high frequencies
and very-- almost nonexistent
at low frequencies.
Because low-frequency sound
can bend around the head
very easily.
So we had, I think,
for 200 Hertz.
Even for a sound source located
directly off to the side
absolutely 0 ILD.
For 6,000 Hertz,
we have a huge ILD.
So ILDs are not very
important at low frequencies.
If you go in to the LSO
and record the frequency
responsivity of the neurons
there from measurements
of their tuning curve.
Now, remember what
a tuning curve was?
Tuning curve, we had
sort of over and over.
It was a plot of
sound frequency.
On the y-axis is sound
pressure level for a response.
And we have the
v-shaped functions
and we picked off the
most sensitive frequency.
And that's the CF of the neuron.
Neurons in the superior olivary
complex have beautiful CFs.
And you could do a
CF mapping, which
is what's done in this study.
So in the LSO-- right here, you
find CFs from 0 to 1 kilohertz.
Right in this part
from 4 to 10 kilohertz.
In this part here,
20 kilohertz and up.
And this is the typical kind
of funny s-shape of the LSO
that you see in coronal
sections in this case of the cat
superior olivary complex.
If you were to do this mapping
in the cochlear nucleus,
you'd find a lot of
cochlear nucleus devoted
to the low CFs, some to the
middle, and some to high.
In the LSO, you have a
lot of the LSO devoted
to the high CFs, which is where
ILD cues are very prominent.
So it makes sense that where
you're processing ILDs,
you devote a lot of neurons to
responding to the frequencies
where the cue is very salient.
The MNTB, which
projects into the LSO,
has a similar disproportionately
large representation
of high CFs.
The MSO is just the opposite.
There's hardly any MSO
devoted to the very highest
frequencies.
And remember, last
time we talked
about ITDs being ambiguous
at high frequencies
because the interaural time
difference is still the same,
but the sound can go through
one or even more complete
cycles by the time it
gets to the other ear.
And so you can't
tell what ITD you're
working with at these
high frequencies.
On the other hand,
where these ILD cues
were weak at low
frequencies, the ITDs
are strong and salient.
And there's a lot of MSO devoted
to the low characteristic
frequencies where the
ITDs are prominent.
So that's what this
text means, that there's
sort of a disproportionate
amount of territory
in these nuclei based
on where the cue is
important in the
frequency domain.
Now, we have a little bit of
an issue here with the LSO.
This LSO on this side is going
to respond to sound sources
on this side of the body.
And remember in most
sensory systems,
there's a crossing
such that stimuli
on the right side of the
body evoke neural responses
on the left side of the brain.
This LSO has sort
of got it backwards.
It's responding with excitation
to sound sources on the right.
Well, that's taken
care of by virtue
of the ascending
projections from the LSO
to the next higher
center, which is
the Inferior Colliculus, or IC.
And that's diagrammed
here in this next slide.
And this shows the
projections of the LSO.
Again, the LSO on the left side
projecting across the midline
to the inferior colliculus
on the right side.
And that projection
would then predict
that if a sound source was
over on this right side
and exciting the LSO neuron,
that message would then
get in a big way to the inferior
colliculus on the left side.
So that inferior
colliculus would then
respond to sounds on the
right side of the body.
For a while, this field
was a little mystified
because there's
also a projection
from the left LSO
to the left IC.
It ended up being an
inhibitory projection.
So this projection here
that stays on the same side
is mostly inhibitory.
It's not exactly clear what
that does, but it's there.
You can sort of discount it in
terms of the mapping of stimuli
on one side of the
body to responses
on the other side of the body.
The MSO doesn't
have such a problem,
I'll just say in passing.
The MSO, just because
of its ITD map--
if you go back and review
last week's lecture,
you'll see that
the MSO is already
mapping ITDs for sound
sources on the opposite side
of the body.
Now, there's been a lot of work,
especially in the early days
of auditory neural
science, on looking
at the effect of lesions.
And lesions are a
little bit hard to do
in a complex as hard as the
superior olivary complex.
Because if you go in and
try to destroy the LSO,
invariably right next door
is the MSO on one side.
And right next door is the MNTB.
It's very hard to make selective
lesions in the superior olive.
When you get to the
inferior colliculus-- oh,
there's a big nucleus.
And you can go in and
you can destroy it
in an experimental
animal on just one side.
When that is done, and the
animal is trained in a task
to localize where the
sound is coming from,
it's very clear that a lesion
of the inferior colliculus
on the right side makes the
animal unable to localize
sounds on the opposite
side of the body.
So lesion in the right
inferior colliculus,
the animal can't localize
sounds on the opposite side.
The animal still can localize
sounds on the ipsilateral hemi
field, in the side that
you didn't lesion on
because the other colliculus
that's still there that's
not lesioned can
perform the task.
If you lesion both
inferior colliculi,
the animal can't
localize sounds anywhere.
But it's very
clear that a lesion
on one side of the
auditory pathway
here makes the animal
unable to localize sounds
in the opposite hemi field.
So that's a theme for
sensory processing
that stimuli on one
side of the body
are mapped to neural nuclei on
the opposite side of the brain.
And that's very clear
in the auditory pathway.
Now, I think last time when we
had the demonstrations of ITDs
and ILDs in headphones where
we could present one and not
the other, someone said,
well, it sounded a little bit
like when we had an ITD when
the sound was on the left side.
And then later, we had an ILD
with sound on the left side.
They sounded a little bit
the same, as if the sound
could be put on one side
by either ITD and ILD.
And that was an
interesting comment
because of the phenomenon called
time intensity trading, which
you can do with headphones.
I won't demonstrate it because
it's so clear to explain it.
You can have someone
listen in headphones
and you can make-- let's see.
An ITD such that when
that's presented alone,
the sound is perceived as if
it's coming from the left side.
You can also present with those
headphones the same sound,
but make now in
this case an ILD.
So the sound is higher
on the right side
so that it sounds like it's
coming from the right side.
So now we have the
time cues making
you think it's
coming from the left.
The intensity cues
making you think
it's coming from the right.
When you put those
two things together,
which you can do
artificially with headphones,
you find in some
cases that the sound
sounds like it's coming
from straight ahead.
And this is called trading
for time and intensity,
or time/intensity trading.
And you can balance
one with the other.
If you do a lot of
sound level on one side
and just a little time
on the other side,
it sounds like it's
off to the right.
If you do them equal, it sounds
like it's straight ahead.
If you do a lot of time, a
big ITD and a little ILD,
it sounds like it's a
little off to the left.
It's a very clear
psychophysical phenomena.
Where do you find neural
responses that correlate with
time/ intensity trading?
Well, you find it in places like
the inferior colliculus, where
inputs from the LSO and
the MSO first converge.
So both LSO and MSO project up
into the inferior colliculus.
And here, you have
the kind of responses
that are shown on this graph.
This x-axis is now a time
axis, except it's ITD.
One side is the inhibitory lead.
The sound is delayed so that the
ITD is from the opposite ear.
This is the side
so that the time
is delayed from the
ear on the same side
as the inferior colliculus
you're recording from.
And clearly, this neuron
is sensitive to that ITD
if you vary it.
This is the percent
neural response.
100% would be up here, 0
response would be up here.
Now, what's varied
as the parameter here
is the interaural
level difference.
So in this case, the
contralateral ear
is-- it looks like 35.
And the ipsilateral ear is 45.
They've kept the contralateral
ear the same for the most part.
And the ipsilateral
ear level has changed.
And clearly, changing
the level also
has a big effect on
the neural response.
So here, for the first time
in the auditory pathway, where
we're finding ITD and
ILD responses together
in single neurons--
in a big way.
You find them in a small
way in the MSO and the LSO.
But this is a huge effect here.
And probably, there
is the first place
where you might have neural
correlates of your perception
for time/intensity trading.
So that's one phenomenon I
want to cover that probably
has a neural
correlate at the level
of the inferior colliculus.
And here's another one.
We've been dealing with
very simple stimuli that
have just, say,
one ITD or one ILD.
When you get into a room, it
becomes much more complicated
because of echoes off
the walls and ceiling
and floor of the room.
And there's some very
interesting experiments
that are done with more natural
stimuli like you find in rooms.
And we'll go over
just a few of them.
So here-- and this
is an observer
listening to a sound source
off to the observer's left.
And the direct sound
is indicated by A here.
And most of these data deal with
the interaural time difference
because this is a
fairly low frequency.
This interaural time difference
of the direct sound indicated
by this big arrow in the air
here favors the left ear.
It's going to be arriving
at the left ear first
and the right ear
a little bit later.
So if you just had that
sound, the subject,
obviously, would
report that the sound
is coming from the left side.
And this is a plot of the sound
for the left and right ear
if you just had this
arrow in A here.
And in green, it's the
interaural time difference
for just that direct sound.
So you can see it's
a fairly stable ITD
and it's a negative
ITD just by convention.
Left ear is going to
be negative here, ITD.
And this is an ITD
in milliseconds
of 0.4 milliseconds.
And remember, we said if it was
directly off to the left side,
it would be about 0.6.
If it were straight
ahead, it would be 0.
So what's the sound
stimulus here?
Well, this is, again,
changing things a little bit.
We've been talking about very
simple pure tone stimuli,
or clicks.
This paper is from
a German group.
And French or German speakers
have this lovely speech sound,
which is called like a
trill or rolled R. And I,
for the life of me,
cannot do this stimulus.
But I'll try.
It's something like [ROLLING R].
As if you were to pronounce
the word in German "reich."
Or in French, [INAUDIBLE].
It's impossible for me
to do that because I
don't speak those languages.
But anyway, here's
the sound stimulus
with all the echoes added in.
And one of these traits just
shows the left ear input
and the right ear input.
And these peaks here
are the trills of the R.
You can see them of just the
left ear input as considered.
So it's a trill
of the R. And you
can see how many
milliseconds happened
between each of those
parts of the trill.
Maybe like 40
milliseconds or so.
Now, when the subject
is in a normal room,
a lot more happens than
just the direct sound.
Some of the sound comes
from the source, the R here,
and bounces off the wall
to the subject's right.
Some of the sound goes
beyond the subject's head
and bounces off the
wall to the right,
and then the wall behind the
subject and comes back there.
And this drawing
here is when you
take into account several of
these reflections in addition
to the direct sound.
And the overall ITD is
still plotted in green.
And look what a mess it is.
The ITD is all over the place.
It starts out like it should
from just the direct sound.
It's negative here.
But then real quickly,
it goes past 0.
And it goes way up here
and it bounces around,
then it goes back down again.
It's all over the map.
So where do you
think that subject
says the sound is coming from?
Do you think the subject
says, I can't tell,
it's all over the place?
Well, you've been
in rooms and you've
listened to speakers in rooms.
You're hearing me
right now and there's
a lot of sound coming off the
walls to get into your ears
on both sides.
If you add up the
reflections from the walls
to the side and beyond,
it's a lot greater
than the direct sound in
terms of the total energy.
But you can close
your eyes and you
can know that I'm standing
up here to this side of you.
You don't have any
trouble with that.
And if you just do a
very careful experiment
with this subject,
the direct sound,
and a couple of
reflections like here.
And you have the
subject with a pointer.
That subject will say the
speaker is over there.
It's on the left side.
It's not behind or
to the wrong side.
So how do we do that?
Well, there is something
called the precedence effect,
which is very important here.
Which helps you in
a situation where
you have lots of reflections.
And what does precedence mean?
Well, precedence means
something is dominating
or something is
the most important.
And in these cases, if
you look very carefully
at the complex sound,
when you add up
all the reflections
with the direct sound,
you can see, if you have
really good eyesight,
that right at the beginning of
the sort of burst of energy,
the first thing to get
to the subject ears
is coming from the left side.
So the left ear input here
right at the beginning
of these trills starts out.
There's a bigger left ear input.
And that's why you
have a negative ITD
right at the
beginning of the trill
before it starts going crazy.
It turns out that the
most important part
of this signal for localizing
where the sound comes from
is in the initial
few milliseconds.
So subjects bias
their impression
of where the sound
is coming from right
at the beginning of the sound.
And they tend to suppress or
ignore all the remaining parts
of the sound, at least
for localization purposes.
So what takes precedence
here is the very initial part
of the sound signal.
And that's what the
precedence effect is.
It's sometimes called by a
different name when you're
dealing with speech--
the Haas effect.
But the precedence
effect is more
general for any type of sound.
And it really means
that when you're
in a complex environment with
all sorts of reflections,
you pay attention to the
very first, or initial, sound
and ignore the others.
So the precedence effect
can be studied carefully
by just narrowing it down to a
direct sound and one reflection
by this kind of setup here.
So here's a subject
listening to two speakers
in an anechoic room.
And I think we've talked
about anechoic rooms before.
Anechoic rooms
have these baffles
on the walls and the floor.
This person is seated
in a chair in a mesh,
so he doesn't fall
into the baffles
below him, which are
also absorbing sound
on the floor of the room.
There are baffles in
the ceiling as well.
So whatever sound
this is presented
goes right to the subject.
If it goes beyond him, it
goes to this wall over here
and is completely absorbed.
So there are no reflections.
There's just the direct sound.
So you can say, well, one of
these is the direct sound.
And a little bit
later, I'm going
to introduce a
second sound coming
from somewhere else,
which is the echo.
So this might simulate
a wall on this side
of the subject that reflects.
In this case, there's
no reflection.
But you can say this is an
artificial echo presented
by this second loudspeaker.
What happens if we change
the timing between those two
sounds?
And that's what's plotted here.
This is the delay
between the first sound
and the second sound
in milliseconds.
Now, for ITDS and
sound localization,
remember we've been talking
about ITDs way down here from 0
to about 0.6 milliseconds.
That's where you have sound
localization way down here.
And when you do a delay
that's that short,
it sounds to a subject like
there's just one sound.
If the ITD is at
exactly 0, this subject
will perceive the
sound source being
directly in between
these two speakers.
As the lagging sound
gets greater and greater,
the subject will start to
perceive that the source goes
to the original or
first sound emitted.
And when the delay comes
to the maximal delay
for the size of the
human head, which
is about 0.6
milliseconds right here,
the subject will
perceive that it's only
coming from that
initial loudspeaker.
Then, as delays get
further and further on,
up between about
0.6 milliseconds
and a little over
10 milliseconds,
the subject will still say,
I still hear one sound.
And it's still coming
from that speaker.
But now it's starting to
sound a little bit different.
In fact, it doesn't
sound as dead anymore.
It sounds like I'm in
a pretty live room.
So what's a live room?
A room that's reverberant,
like a church or a cathedral.
It sounds roomy.
It sounds like there's volume.
Over here, this is the region
called the precedence effect,
where you ignore
that lagging sound.
And it still sounds like
there's just one sound,
but it sounds different.
This is the region of the
precedence effect from 0.6
to maybe 10 milliseconds or so.
Then, as the delay
becomes longer and longer,
you start to
perceive two sounds.
You hear, let's say, a
click from the first speaker
and a second click a little bit
later from the second speaker.
And now, the delay
is long enough
so you actually hear an echo.
You hear two sounds, an
initial sound and an echo.
So that's the perception.
And there's this big region here
called the precedence effect.
So I have a
demonstration, if you
don't believe me, about echoes.
And the demonstration is
really vivid, I think.
The echoes become more-- you
don't hear the echoes here
because it's a
precedence effect.
Maybe it sounds a
little bit more roomy,
but you don't hear an echo.
But there definitely
are echoes there.
You may not be able
to perceive them.
So let me play
this demonstration.
The demonstration is--
I think, the best part
of the demonstration is
someone taking a brick
and hitting it with a hammer.
And that makes a
big click, right?
Well, after that big
sound, that impact sound,
there's some echoes.
You can't hear them
very well except when
they do this neat trick on
this demonstration, which
is to play the sound
recording backwards.
And then, the
echoes start first,
and then you hear the
hammer hitting the brick.
They also have
some text on here.
And they read the text, and then
they play the text backward.
To me, that's not so obvious.
So they do this demonstration
of hitting the brick.
They do it in an anechoic
room right here first.
There's no echoes.
Second, they do it
in a normal room,
like this room where
there's some reverberation.
But a lot of the
reverberation is
stopped by the
carpet on the floor
and the clothes I'm wearing.
And the seat cushions
absorb some of the echoes.
Then finally, they do this
demonstration a third time.
And they do that backwards, too.
Then they do it a third time
in a very reverberant room,
like a church or a cathedral,
where you hit the brick
and it just sort of
rings for quite a ways.
So let's play this
demonstration and see
if it lives up to
my description.
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
-[INAUDIBLE] echoes.
First, in an anechoic room.
Then, in a conference room.
Then finally, in a
very reverberant space.
You will hear a hammer
striking a brick followed
by an old Scottish [INAUDIBLE].
Playing these sounds
backwards focuses
our attention on the
echoes that occur.
From ghoulies and ghosties,
and long-leggedy beasties
and things that go bump in the
night, good lord deliver us.
PROFESSOR: OK, that's forward.
This is backward.
-[SPEAKING BACKWARD]
PROFESSOR: OK, now
the conference room.
-From ghoulies and ghosties,
and long-leggedy beasties
and things that go bump in the
night, good lord deliver us.
[SPEAKING BACKWARD]
PROFESSOR: All right, now
in the reverberant room.
-From ghoulies and ghosties,
and long-leggedy beasties
and things that go bump in the
night, good lord deliver us.
[SPEAKING BACKWARD]
[END AUDIO PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: All right, so I
like especially the sound
of the hammer hitting the
brick played backwards
in the reverberant room
because it's going to pssew.
And all that pssew
leading up to the impact
is the echo that you
just completely discount
because of the precedence
effect in the normal hearing.
OK, so that brings me
up to the special part
of my lecture, which
is the reading.
And this little quotation
is by a musician.
And of course, musicians
love reverberant rooms,
like churches or cathedrals,
or concert halls, or whatever.
So E. Power Biggs, who was
the organist at Harvard
for a long time, made
many famous recordings
of organ music said,
"An organist will
take all the reverberation
time he is given,
and then ask for a bit more,
for ample reverberation is
part of organ music itself.
Many of Bach's organ works
are designed actually
to exploit reverberation.
Consider the pause that follows
the ornamented proclamation
that opens the famous 'Toccata
in D Minor.' Obviously,
this is for the enjoyment of the
notes as they remain suspended
in the air."
So musicians love
reverberations.
And that's the reason that
halls where we appreciate music,
like Boston Symphony Hall--
and they have some measurements
of reverberation time
here for opera houses.
1.3 seconds.
OK, that's the time the
echoes take to decay.
Symphony Hall in
Birmingham, 2.4 seconds.
St. Paul's Cathedral in London,
13 seconds reverberation time.
Now in contrast, when you
have theaters for speech,
like Shakespeare
drama theaters, you
don't want all those
reverberations.
You want, for example,
a theater for speech
here is quoted at having
a reverb time of 0.9
seconds because you don't
want all these echoes
to interfere with your
interpretation of the speech.
And average living
room, 0.4 seconds.
Reverberation time is given
for the great outdoors.
Anybody guess?
0.0.
All right.
The outdoors has no
walls, ceiling, or floor.
Now, why are we talking
about this here?
Because in the
inferior colliculus,
you find some neurons that
show precedence-like responses.
And so here is a recording from
an inferior colliculus neuron.
And this was a study where
they used infants and adults,
but these are just the
data for the adult.
And the stimuli are two sounds.
I think they are clicks.
The first sound starts
at time 10 milliseconds.
So this is the time axis.
And this is the
dot raster display.
So each little
dot here-- they're
a little bit hard to
see-- is a neural spike.
And there are many, many trials.
OK, perhaps 50 or 100 trials.
And you can see reliably on
all the trials, the neuron
responded to the first stimulus.
When the second
stimulus occurred
at 101 millisecond
delayed, the neuron
also faithfully responded
to the second stimulus.
But as the delay was
shortened less and less,
the neuron eventually stopped
responding for a delay
that's-- in this case,
it looks like about 20
or so milliseconds.
Well, this is certainly
precedence-like behavior.
That the neural response to the
second stimulus is attenuated.
This delay, where
this particular neuron
starts cutting out,
is not exactly where
we stop losing the
precedence effect in humans.
This is from an animal.
And this animal is anesthetized,
so many of the processes
are slowed down by anesthesia.
And perhaps the animal
is a little cool,
which might make these
things abnormally long.
But certainly, this kind of
precedence-like responses
are on the way toward
explaining the precedence effect
at the level of the
inferior colliculus.
And this is the work
of Ruth Litovsky
from University of Wisconsin.
OK, so now I want to
shift gears a little bit
and go onto a different
species, which is the barn owl.
And this is mostly the
work of-- originally,
Mark Konishi at Caltech.
And now, Eric Knudsen at
Stanford in California.
And why did they choose
to study the barn owl?
So many of us study
mammalian models
because we want to know what
human hearing is all about.
And it's hard to record
from human brains,
but we want to choose an
animal that's like the human.
So we use a mammal.
Why did they choose
the barn owl?
A lot of successes
in neuroscience
have been choosing
an animal that's
specialized for a certain task.
And barn owls are very
specialized for hearing.
So if you take a barn
owl and blindfold the owl
and turn a mouse
loose in a room.
As long as the mouse is
making a little bit of sound,
the barn owl can quickly
fly over to the mouse
and catch it and eat it.
So the prey of barn owls
are mice and insects,
like grasshoppers that
are down on the floor.
And if you've ever seen or
watched a barn owl hunting,
you can clearly
see them at night.
They don't come
out during the day.
But at night they come out.
I watched one a lot of evenings
when I was in California.
The owl would come and
sit on a basketball hoop.
And it would just perch there.
And it would move
its head all around.
And I didn't really know what
it was doing at the time,
until later, when I read some
of this work and it said that
owls' eyes cannot
move in their head.
The owl's eyes are fixed.
So this beautiful control
of the eyeball position
that we have in
mammalian eye control
is not present in most birds.
And certainly is not
present in the owl.
So to move eyes, you
have to move the head.
And of course, you're
moving the ears as well.
In the barn owl,
and in other words,
you don't have an external
pinna, which we said
introduces a lot of help
to localizing sounds.
But the barn owl
is a unique bird
in that there is some
external stuff going on,
which is called
the facial rough.
And that's formed by feathers
on the face of the owl.
You can see they're sort of
like fan-shaped down here.
And over here, they
go over the ear canal.
There's an ear canal, certainly.
They go over the ear canal
in this perioral flap.
And the opening for sound
to get in is below that.
And also, above it
there's an opening.
So the barn owl
doesn't have a pinna,
but it has some
modified feathers
on the front of its face.
Barn owl feathers are
also interesting that they
are modified.
The feathers on the
wings are modified.
When this owl took off, when I
watched it on that basketball
hoop, every now and then it
would take off and go down
to the basketball court below.
And you couldn't hear anything.
Owl feathers are
specifically designed so even
the air going over them
when the owl flaps its wings
is completely silent because the
owls don't want whatever it's
hunting to hear
them approaching it.
So barn owl wing
feathers are specifically
designed to be
acoustically silent.
OK, so a lot of work has been
done on the barn owl pathway.
Now, this is a
little bit different
because if you've looked at
the brains of avian species,
they're a little bit different.
They evolve differently
than mammals.
But they have some
analogous nuclei.
Here are the cochlear nuclei.
That's with this
little text here.
This is supposed to be the
owl pathway on the left side
and the right side of the brain.
This is the midline
in dashed lines.
The owl cochlear nuclei are
split up into two parts.
And the one that's featured
here is labeled NM.
So NM stands for
Nucleus Magnocellularis.
And so we can all figure
out what this means.
Cellularlaris means the
cell or the nerve cells.
Magno means big.
These are the big cells.
So there's some other parts
of the bird cochlear nuclei
where the cells are smaller.
But this is the
big-- big cell part.
And in nucleus
magnocellularis, you
have beautiful phase locking.
We talked about
that being typical
of the mammalian pathway.
In the cochlear
nucleus, the bushy cells
have good phase locking.
Maybe even better than
the auditory nerve.
In the owl, the
nucleus magnocellularis
neurons have excellent
phase locking.
And so they're keeping track
of the stimulus waveform.
The timing is important to them.
They project centrally.
The one on the left side and
the one on the right side
converge onto a nucleus
that's sensitive to interaural
time differences.
That's the avian
equivalent of the MSO.
And it's called NL,
Nucleus Laminaris.
OK, lamina means sheet.
OK, and this is a sheet.
It looks like that
anyway in the anatomy.
And there, the neurons
are sensitive to ITDs.
And there's a beautiful
Jeffress model there.
Most of the papers
on the mammalian MSO
say, we know there's
a beautiful Jeffress
model in the avian
nucleus laminaris.
But in the mammal, we're
starting to rethink it.
This is a beautiful
Jeffress model
where you find
neural responses that
are very strongly peaked to ITD.
So they fire for a certain ITD.
This is the firing rate.
But don't fire much
at all to other ITDs.
They're strongly tuned to ITD.
The nucleus laminaris in turn
projects across the midline
here to the inferior colliculus.
And we haven't talked
about it, but there
are several subregions of
the inferior colliculus.
The big one is called the ICC.
And that's called the
Inferior Colliculus Central
part, or central nucleus.
That's true in mammals as well.
That's the big part.
Some would call it the core.
That's what's indicated
here, the core
of the inferior colliculus.
And it, in turn,
projects to other places,
like the lateral part.
And it finally projects from
the lateral part to the ICX.
And the ICX is the
Inferior Colliculus.
And X stands for External.
So the external part of
the inferior colliculus.
And there is where some
very interesting responses
take place in the barn owl.
And we'll look at those
responses right now.
So these experiments
were first done
by Mark Konishi in, I
believe, the 1970s at Caltech.
And the experimental
subject is seen.
Here is the barn owl right here.
And where are his wings?
Well, his wings are folded down.
And he's in a little, sort of
like a tube sock, if you will.
His wings are constrained.
And the tube sock is mounted
on a pole or a pedestal.
And he's just sitting there.
He can move his head.
Actually, in many of
these experiments,
the head is clamped.
But he's sitting there.
He's awake.
He's listening to the sounds.
And the sound is
presented by a speaker.
The speaker is on a big hoop.
You see that hoop?
And the speaker is
sitting on the hoop.
And there's a little
motor in the speaker.
And the speaker can be moved
by driving the motor over here.
Or you can move the motor
the other direction.
You can move the speaker over
here or down here or up here,
wherever you want to on
that hoop the speaker can
be driven by the motor.
And because the hoop is mounted
on two posts on the side,
the whole hoop can be swung
up or it can be swung down.
OK, so you can put that speaker
anywhere this way and anywhere
up or down that you want to.
And so you can put that speaker
in the entire-- any position
you want to in the entire
frontal hemi field of the owl.
And I suppose they
didn't do that.
I suppose you could put it in
the rear hemi field as well.
But these data are just from the
frontal hemi field of the owl.
And since the owl's head is
mounted and is not moving,
you can apply a little
local anesthetic
and open up the skull.
And you can advance an electrode
into the ICX, the External
Nucleus of the
Inferior Colliculus,
and make recordings from
single neurons there.
And in this case, the
recordings are made from the ICX
on the right side.
And what's found
in this response
plot here is these neurons have
restricted receptive fields
in space.
So what's plotted here is
the neuro-responsive field
in dashed lines and
the most vigorous part
in the shaded area there.
And this axis, the
x-axis, is azimuth.
And the y-axis is elevation.
And this is a fairly restrictive
part of the whole hemi field.
And one of these-- this is one
response area for one neuron.
And a whole bunch
of these rectangles
are plotted down here with
a little diagram of the owl
right in the center
of this globe.
So there's 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9,
10-- about a dozen neural
receptive fields for ICX
neurons in that owl.
Notice that they're
all fairly discrete.
That is, it only
responds when the speaker
is in a certain part of the
frontal field of the owl.
Notice also that we're
recording from the right side.
And most of the receptive fields
are off to the left of the owl.
They're on the opposite side.
So clearly, sound
stimuli on one side
are mapped to the
opposite brain side.
That's not true for
these three, but they're
close to the midline.
Most of the receptive fields
are not straight ahead.
They're actually
down below the owl.
There's one or two that are
just a little bit above,
but there are none
that are way above.
Most of them are
down below the owl.
Remember, the owl is sitting
on the basketball hoop
and he's listening for
targets down below.
This makes a lot of sense that
most of the receptive fields
are down below the owl, not
at the same level of the owl.
It doesn't care about
a mouse making a slam
dunk at the other hoop.
It cares about the mouse
down on the basketball court.
And finally, maybe the most
important and most interesting
part of these responses
is the progression
of where the
receptive fields are
in space versus where they
are along the dimensions
of the ICX.
So that this receptive field was
located over here in the ICX.
And as you move this way and
encountered a different neuron,
it was located over here
and its receptive field
was moved over
this way a little.
As you move further
in that direction,
you encountered another
receptive field even further
in this dimension.
And then finally, way
over here laterally,
you encountered these
receptive fields
that were way off to the side.
So along this dimension
of auditory space,
receptive fields were
found along this dimension
of the ICX.
There was also a
mapping going this way.
This is clearly then what
some people call a space map.
A mapping of auditory
space into position
within a certain part, the
ICX, of the owl's brain.
OK, it's a beautiful mapping.
Neuroscientists love mappings.
You've heard me talk
about tonotopic mappings
out the wazoo.
We love tonotopic mappings
because CF is then
very important.
This clearly is important
to have organization
of the receptive fields on
a dimension in the brain.
People have spent many,
many years looking
for these kind of mappings in
the mammalian auditory pathway
and not found them.
People have looked in
the inferior colliculus,
in the analogous part,
the central part,
the external part.
It is hard to record
from the external part
of the mammalian
inferior colliculus
because it's a small
edge structure,
but it has not been found.
People have looked in
the medial geniculate,
in the auditory cortex,
and looked for organization
of spatial receptive
fields and not found them.
So on nuclei in the main
part of the auditory pathway,
you do not find space maps
in the mammalian system.
So the one place you
find spatial organization
in the mammal is in the
mammalian superior colliculus.
And you're probably going, huh?
I thought you just said the
superior colliculus is visual?
Well, it is.
But it's a layered structure
that, if I'm not mistaken,
the top three layers
are exclusively visual.
But if you go down to lower
layers, the bottom layers
of the superior colliculus,
you start to encounter neurons
that respond to visual as
well as auditory stimuli.
And you may have talked
about the visual mapping
of the superior colliculus.
And those neurons
in the deep layers
that are also responsive
to auditory stimuli--
they're mostly ILD sensitive.
They're mapped in line with
the visual receptive fields.
They're also space mapped
to a certain extent.
Now, that nucleus clearly
is not on the main drag
of the auditory pathway.
The auditory pathway is cochlear
nucleus, superior olive,
inferior colliculus, medial
geniculate and cortex.
So you do have a space map
in the mammalian deep layers
of the superior
colliculus, but not
on the main parts of the
mammalian auditory pathway.
So that's been the finding.
Now, that's negative evidence.
It's not clear that I
won't be back here teaching
the course next year.
And we'll read a
paper that says,
ah, space map in wherever.
But it hasn't been found so
far with this one exception.
Now, the paper that we
read for today's class
talks about-- back
to the barn owl.
A place in the barn
owl, which is-- they
call it the optic
tectum in the birds.
But it's analogous to the
superior colliculus in mammals.
A place where, as I said, you
find auditory spacing maps that
are in line with
visual space maps.
And they do a very interesting
and elegant experiment
where one of those
maps is distorted.
And you study the resulting
effect on the other map.
OK, so how did they do that?
So this is n owl, but
it's a juvenile owl.
An owl chick.
And it's wearing some
interesting things on its eyes.
Those aren't its eyes.
Those are some prisms
that the investigators
have put on the owl's eyes.
And they deflect the visual
field a certain amount
depending on the
size of the prism.
And I can't remember
what the deflection was.
I seem to remember 30 degrees.
So the visual field is
deflected 30 degrees.
And as I said before, the owl's
eyes are fixed in the head.
So putting on these
goggles, no matter
what-- the goggles are going to
move if the owl moves its head.
So no matter what the owl does,
the visual receptive fields
of all these neurons,
everything in vision
is shifted 30 degrees.
This is normal.
These might be receptive fields
from neurons in the brain
somewhere.
This is when the
prisms are added.
Here, you've shifted the
visual receptive field.
The auditory
receptive field-- you
haven't changed the ears at all.
The auditory receptive
field is the same.
What's found when you do
that in juvenile owls,
you come back eight weeks later.
You find, oh my gosh, the
auditory receptive field
has actually moved.
It shifted.
You knew where you ere
recording from in the brain.
In this case, the recordings
are made in the optic tectum,
in the superior colliculus.
You know the dimensions
and you come back
and you're expecting to see
auditory receptive fields
like that, but
they've been shifted.
So juvenile owls with
prism experience,
given a number of
weeks to compensate,
shift the auditory
receptive fields
so that the two are
back in alignment.
This group has also
shown that if you
do this experiment
with adult owls,
you don't get such shifts.
You come back to an adult
owl with these same prisms,
eight weeks later you
have still a mismatch.
So plasticity clearly takes
place in the juveniles
and not in the adults.
And they've then likened
it to those old folks of us
trying to learn a
foreign language.
It's really tough because
we didn't have experience
with it while we were juveniles.
So neural plasticity and
these learning new things--
if this is learning something,
it's a bit of a stretch.
But it's more difficult to
learn things as an adult
than it is juveniles.
Now, the experiment-- an even
further twist in this paper
that we read for today, which is
now the subject is adult owls.
The recordings were
made from adult owls.
But there are two groups.
One is a plain, old
control adult owl.
The other is an adult owl
that when it was a juvenile
had experience with the prisms.
That experience was long
ago, six months before.
The prisms were on
for eight weeks or so.
These shifts took place.
The prisms were removed.
The owl is allowed
to grow up and become
an adult with normal vision.
Then, take these two groups of
owls, put the prisms on again.
We've already said that
adults don't have the capacity
to remap.
So many of them just
stayed the same.
These are the open circles here.
The auditory receptive
field is the same.
This is before the prisms.
This is eight weeks after.
The open circles are
from the adult owls
that didn't have any
juvenile prism experience.
But the adult owls-- they're
now adults with the prisms on.
The adult owls with the
juvenile prism experiences,
one of the neurons
is recorded here.
It has an auditory
receptive field
that's shifted to
make it in line
with the shifted visual
receptive fields.
This is now showing
then that adults
that have the
juvenile experience
have some plastic ability to
re-map their auditory receptive
field so that you have alignment
with the visual receptive
fields.
Clearly, a very
interesting experiment.
Showing, if you will,
a type of maybe memory
trace that these owls
have retained something
that was altered by the
juvenile experience.
So what could that be?
The group has in
other studies gone on
and looked at the projections
between these two boxes
here from the central
nucleus of the colliculus
to the external nucleus.
And clearly, shown in juvenile
animals that have the prism
experiences that the
axons that were headed
for direct innervation
take a little change
and they regrow some
axonal projections.
They've studied these.
And it looks like this regrowth
of axon between those two
areas.
And that's what was meant
by this little circle that
says locus or site of
plasticity is manifested
by a change in growth
of axons right there.
And maybe those
adult animals that
have juvenile
experience retain some
of those axonal projections
that have been changed
as a result of the experience.
And clearly, it takes
many weeks for axons
to grow or change
their connections.
Maybe that's the thing
that's much easier
to do if you're
a juvenile animal
and you're reacting to
these changed stimuli.
Another way to change
responses there
is to have everything
connected to everything,
but certain things emphasize
certain synapses very strong
and the weak ones not emphasize.
Maybe when you have
the prism experience,
the previously
de-emphasized synapses
become upregulated without
any change of axons.
But clearly, this
group has shown
that the axons have changed
their growth patterns.
So that could be a mechanism
for the plasticity.
And I think that's all
I wanted to say today.
So I have five minutes
if you guys want
to ask questions about anything.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you go
over how prisms actually
change auditory
perception again?
Like, how are the prisms--
PROFESSOR: Back to precedence?
Is that what you're--
AUDIENCE: How are
prisms changing--
PROFESSOR: How are prisms?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: That's not clear.
What's clear is that the
fields are mismatched.
AUDIENCE: So we don't
know why that happens?
PROFESSOR: That's correct.
Yeah.
But I presume what is
happening to the owl
during these eight weeks is
the owl is seeing an object
and hearing it as well.
For example, a mouse down here.
The owl sees it
and it goes for it.
But actually, because its
visual fields are off,
it goes over here and
the object is over here.
But the auditory cues, if
it paid attention to them,
it would go here.
So it's sensing a
misalignment in experience.
There's no training
involved here,
but the owls are allowed
to hunt prey and experience
environmental sounds.
So they clearly then have
a mismatch between vision
and audition in
these eight weeks.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does
this sort of then,
I guess suggest that the
auditory input is somehow
more important?
Because rather than say a visual
input shifting [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes, you could say that.
I mean, it would be interesting
to do the converse experiment.
Keep the eyeballs normal
and somehow distort
the auditory receptive fields.
So you could do that with
ITDs by putting a tube
and lengthening the
ITD on one side.
That would be an interesting
sort of counter experiment
to get at what
you're asking about.
It would distort the other cue.
OK, great.
We'll see you back
on Wednesday then.